welcome to their famous Friday I believe
that whatever goal you have whatever
mission you're on whatever challenges in
front of you somebody has already solved
it so the fastest way to grow is to
model success find what work for them
and apply their strategies to your
business so you can achieve similar
success yourself today we're going to
learn from Arthur Blank and Bernie
Marcus the cofounders of the Home Depot
when blanket Marcus started Home Depot
they wanted to make it the Sears of the
home improvement industry people laughed
at them and told them they could never
do it
and today Home Depot is more than twice
the size of Sears here's how they did it
so in the 1970s Blanken Marcus were both
executives at a home improvement company
called handy Dan's in Southern
California
then turnaround artist Sanford sigilyph
bought the company and he was known for
gutting executives out of the new
companies that he bought blanket Marcus
thought they were safe because handy Dan
was making so much money that Sanford
sigilyph would be stupid to fire them
they were wrong and in 1978 he let them
go so two decided now is a time to be
entrepreneurs they were testing a
discounting strategy in one of the Handy
Dan's locations before they were let go
it was working and they wanted to expand
it to the other hand e Dan's
but now they thought hey we could do
this ourselves so they took over two
former treasure island stores in
suburban Atlanta and set up shop they
started the business off of two rules
great prices and great service they
stocked the shelves slash the prices and
personally hired all of the staff on
opening day they gave their kids stacks
of $1 bills to hand out to every new
customer who came into the door they
figured they'd be out of money by noon
but by six o'clock their kids were still
chasing people down in the parking lot
begging them to come into the store it
was a huge disaster they were so
disappointed that Marcus's wife wouldn't
let him shave for three days she didn't
want him to have a razor in his hand and
she was afraid of what he might do
by day three there was a little bit of
hope one of the customers came back with
some okra as a gift to the founders to
say thank you for the great service that
we had in your store even though none of
their marketing efforts worked out word
of mouth started to spread because they
focus on great prices and great service
people started to come back they started
to tell the
and they started to buy more blanking
markets wanted people to feel safe and
comfortable into being their own mr. and
mrs. fix it so that you didn't always
have to call a plumber or a contractor
to help you out
they hired great and friendly staff that
would help you figure out what you
needed to solve the job they also held
workshops and clinics to teach you how
you could do things yourself and that
focus on amazing service helped the
company grow find something that you're
great at find something that you really
believe in give people a reason to talk
about you and come back and you might be
on your way to building the next billion
dollar business as well believe those of
you watching like your video subscribe
to the channels team or just like it
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon it's cold it's cold we got
to go maybe we should do it again no oh
wow look at their colors now should we
do it again look at that okay that's it
we're done believe sign up for the
newsletter for more belief
you